désormais entre Veigné et
Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine l'autoroute A10
étant deux fois trois voies dans les
deux sens de circulation près de quatre
années de travaux pour permettre de
fluidifier aujourd'hui le trafic alors
que la fréquentation augmente notamment
celle des poils lourds la 10 et l'un des
axes majeurs en Europe Faustine uno avec
Florent Clavel
ça y est après 4 ans de travaux la
troisième voie dans les deux sens est
ouverte à la circulation le débalisage
vient d'avoir lieu l'État avait confié
ce projet qualifié d'utilité publique
avancée autoroutes devient du réalisé 10
ponts enjambant l'infrastructure
déconstruit puis reconstruit pour
atteindre les dimensions d'une deux fois
trois voies une infrastructure censée
fluidifier et sécuriser davantage cette
section de l'A10 qui est un des axes
majeurs de circulation en France et en
Europe comme le rappel Eric Somer
directeur opérationnel chez VINCI
autoroute on est autour de 35000
véhicules jours aujourd'hui avec un taux
de poids lourds de l'ordre de 20%. c'est
significatif dans le paysage européen
par contre attention c'est une
infrastructure des mobilité du quotidien
vous avez l'essentiel du trafic si on
infrastructure comme c'est là qui est du
trafic local
les poids lourds qui viennent de
Belgique et qui vont en Espagne sont
très rares la plupart ce sont
effectivement des destinations qui sont
soit intra métropole soit à proximité de
la métropole
ou de Châtellerault ou de Poitiers donc
la 10 a été élargi sur 24 km entre
Veigné et Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine pour
les communes concernées l'impact attendu
est une possible réduction de la
circulation sur les départements comme
l'explique Patrick Michaud maire de
Veigné et vice-président au département
en charge des routes il y aura une
incidence et elle sera d'autant plus
flagrante le jour où on arrivera à
mettre en place des moyens de transport
en terme de mobilité pour tout ce qui
est les zones périurbaines ce qu'on
appelle les bus à haut rendement de
service puisque ça évitera l'auto
sollisme ça évitera effectivement que
que chacun prenne sa voiture
Vinci autoroute a financé en totalité ce
projet
244 millions d'euros l'entreprise mise
sur une hausse du trafic et donc des
recettes de péage pour rentabiliser cet
investissement à partir de 2034